guys I want you to understand something
the way you win with money is you begin
to control your behaviors it's the only
variable you can control you have to
change the person in your mirror you got
to have that moment like my friend Les
Brown the great motivator says where you
finally say I've had it I am sick and
tired of being sick and tired I've had
it and when you have that moment only
then are you ready to change
I just previewed a video that we're
going to put up on our channel soon you
guys are going to want to watch it this
guy lost 400 pounds you know I did cuz
he almost died he was over 600 pounds he
almost died and he said he said I've had
it he's laying in the intensive care and
going this has got to change this is no
longer funny and when you look up and
you make $50,000 a year and you're 33
years old you know seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt you know
there is no freaking trick here there is
no little technique there's no debt an
all pill you can take debt version of
Tylenol I'll just pop two of these and
my dad will go away there's no little
company that you can pay a fee to that's
going to make your life okay you got to
go freaking bananas you got to go so
crazy with your get out of debt plan
that your your family thinks you need
counseling and you're broke friends are
making fun of you by the way if you're
broke friends are making fun of your
financial plan you're on track broke
people are making fun of your financial
plan get the point you got to get upset
about this there's some visceral passion
that's involved you know stupidity has a
gravitational pull it will hold you in
an orbit and the only way to break
out of an orbit from that gravitational
pull is there has to be this that this
all at once focused intensity burst of
energy and you can break out of the
centrifugal pull the orbital pull of
gravity that's how you break an orbital
pull stupid has a gravitational pull it
will pull you down too stupid every time
the only way you break away from stupid
is you got to get pissed off
it requires an explosion boom I'm gonna
change my life 2014 is my year I'm not
going to live like the rest of these
idiots that are around me I'm looking at
them going you're a bunch of sheep you
all look alike car payment to car
payment credit card to credit card
student loan to student loan I'm gonna
be in debt my whole life I'm gonna suck
my thumb and hope the government which
is well known for its ability to handle
money will take care of me when I retire
I'm not going to be like that I'm going
to change my life that's how you change
your life it's not an intellectual
exercise except that it is an act of
your will because you don't actually
have to be laying in intensive care to
get that being 600 pounds is a bad idea
you don't have to be on the verge of
bankruptcy to get that seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt is the
gravitational pull of stupid and I got
to get away from stupid cuz stupid
equals broken desperate I don't want to
live my whole life this way I'm going to
change this mess it's not a pleasant
discussion it's blood and guts and sweat
it's messy it smells it's not fun you're
tired cuz all you do is work you work
like a banana man you're going nuts
you just work like 16 jobs you work like
no one else so that later you work like
no one else you pay a price you live
like no one else so that later you get
to live and give like no one else
but if all you do is drive around in a
stupid car that you can't afford living
in a house you can't afford buying
purses and dresses and pants and jeans
and hats that you can't afford and going
on vacations that you can't afford what
you think you are freaking in Congress
Congress can't even do this but they're
doing it are you going to live your life
with this facade of stupidity and
continue to think it's okay don't go
into intensive care to figure it out
don't do what I did don't go into
bankruptcy because I lost everything cuz
I was so amazingly stupid with zeroes on
the end I've done it I know what it
looks like you don't have to do that you
can get the idea that that normal is
looking good and completely freaking
broke in this country and that is not
okay anymore I don't give a rip how you
look or what you drive and I really
don't wanna hear about your freaking
vacation that you went on that you can't
afford I know you can't afford it
because you didn't pay for it and I
don't want to hear about I need to see
my mommy oh shut up you're a grown-up
tell your mommy to get her butt in the
car and drive to see you you got work to
do you got to clean up your freakin mess
this is how you get out of that you have
to get this thing going down inside of
you that I'm displaying here it requires
a level of passion the gravitational
pull of stupid will hold you in that
orbit for the rest of your life and you
will look like the rest of the Sheep
unless you do something about it so you
got to get completely unglued man you
got to bust out of this orbital Pole you
have to kick it in gear like you've
never kicked it in gear in your life but
if you will live like no one else I will
make you a promise
later you'll get to live like no one
else I don't want to drive that car hey
anyone drive that car either but I drove
it I drove like no one else now you know
what I do I Drive like no one else and I
make no apologies for it if you don't
like it you can kiss my ankle I'm gonna
drive a nice car
because I paid a freaking price to get
to do that and I'm okay with that and
some of you aren't that's okay with me
because I don't really exist for my
critics see you kind of get an attitude
going right before you start winning
this is how it works
this is how you get out of debt it's not
an intellectual exercise it's not a
formula and it's not a little pill you
take you got to look in the mirror and
say I'm done with you stupid you're
changing